let's see what we got in here tired of
playing games all that means is she's
been around the block a few times and uh
hoped that it was going somewhere but
got dumped
usually
usually if she says i'm tired of playing
games that's a good indicator she's got
a load of red flags because
guys ditch girls they ghost them when
they've got red flags when they're gonna
invite uh drama or complexity in their
lives by spending any kind of prolonged
period of time with her so
that's what that one means
looking for a real man okay anytime you
see a real man or anything along those
lines
don't let a woman tell you what a real
man is how the hell does she know what a
real man is and most of the time
these words that come out of her mouth
or in her bio come from a chick where
her
mother pushed her father out of the
house and now she wants to tell you what
a real man is give me a break
my kids come first well we kind of
already covered that with aiden
uh proud feminist
let me see here proud feminist where's
feminists that is number two on my red
flag list
do not deal with the proud feminist by
the way if you haven't um
i'm going to put the link down over here
in the ticker but if you haven't got my
free chapter on red flags men must avoid
get on my email list you can download it
once you got on the list there's some
good content i put out there privately
to my email list and
grab the book it's on amazon
it's uh the the free chapters uh
straight out of the book
uh proud feminists are all great lines i
want a guy that makes me laugh means you
have the personality of a cucumber is
what this dude says
uh rich if you did these translations in
your own i'm calling it your best work
well the ones up above are mine these
ones here in the comments are okay okay
here's a good one i suck at texting
this is an important one
this guy defined it as i won't text you
back unless you're chad essentially what
that means straight out of chapter three
of my book
is she doesn't have genuine burning
desire a woman that has genuine burning
desire responds very quickly to text
communication messaging or anything like
that
uh if there's
prolonged periods like hours or even a
day half a day something like that
she's doing something else and it's
generally speaking not you it's another
guy so just heads up on that when you
get the i suck at texting
i want a family man there are some okay
let me just back up there are some
exceptions to that
where
their job might prevent them from having
cell phone and hand for example but
they're pretty rare let me just go to
the next one now i want a family man
he says i still live with my parents and
i'm attached to them
um
i don't know that i agree with that one
so my
my translation of the woman ease term i
want a family man and by the way womenis
is a very very old
uh descriptive term it's been around for
well over 20 years from what i
understand from some of the older blogs
and
content that i've looked at but i want a
family man to me
essentially means
she's been around a block she's been
with the alphas she's been with the
party boys she's been with the chads
she's been with a football team she's
been with a basketball team maybe had a
train run and now she's saying i need a
family
kind of ties into the whole settling
down thing right next one you must have
a car and a job oh that's so good when
i've seen that one too
i don't have my driver's license and
where it's suspended um that's one way
to interpret it the w what she really
means in my opinion though when she says
you must have a car and a job is she's
trying to qualify you
uh to satisfy her hypergamous nature she
she wants to know that she's with
somebody at least equal to her if not
better so
when she says that you must have a car
in a job what she's really saying is you
must have a car and a job that's better
than the car and job that i have okay
if she doesn't have a car or a job a car
any car or any job will do for example
but if you're dealing with a
hundred thousand dollar a year
uh junior accountant uh firm driving a
toyota corolla because that's what good
junior accountants drive because they're
good reliable responsible cars
uh
then she's looking for a guy that makes
at least that and drives a better car
right
you get the idea
man i knocked these things out of the
park
i stopped working out for six plus
months but i'm going back again i
haven't done any physical activity since
gym class in high school
yeah like any time you get i'm you know
like i'm working on this body or um
anything like that that's
you're gonna be dealing with about
average or worse just heads up
uh daniel dpa says highly educated
women's equals women's major
sorry women's study major with a quarter
mill and student loans
yeah i'm not i'm not uh particularly
impressed with the i'm highly educated
crowd
um
you know let's have a piece of paper
framed in mahogany uh with a bunch of
little letters after your name up there
and um you know they're there
they're there they're out there
um they generally come with debt that
they generally or almost always come
with the boss girl sort of attitude
um but uh yeah you will find a lot of
them you know that have worthless
degrees uh cleary
wrote a book on worthless degrees and
you know he broke it all down in there
he talks about it quite often as well on
his channel
done playing games is the source of all
games in her life and past relationships
is what anonymous says that translates
to done playing games equals
she is the source of all games in her
life and past relationships yeah that's
one way to take a look at it hates drama
equals requires drama to live will
literally wither and die if her life
doesn't resemble a soap opera at any
point
um
yeah yeah i can co-sign that
uh in the uk bubbly equals i'm quite
chubby but really friendly so it's okay
is that the same thing here in north
america bubbly bubbly usually means that
they won't shut up uh i think is what i
put up here bubbly is won't stop talking
so in the uk bubbly means
i'm quite chubby but really friendly
hey man you know there's
there's a lid for every pot
you know the interesting thing is
there's
chubby chaser websites for guys looking
for bigger girls but there's no chubby
chaser websites for girls looking for
bigger guys just remember that they
don't exist
i have two cats
equals ovaries are drier than gantry
ovaries are drier than gandy's
flip-flops
um
the uh
the fur baby um
bios or i'm a fur mom
i have three fur babies i have two cats
i have two cats and a dog three cats and
a dog
um
yeah no
no um
not good that's uh you know i could have
made that red flag
on my list and added that there but uh
that's that's definitely uh abort abort
abort
um
self-proclaimed christian and tattoos
self-proclaimed christian with tattoos
and a kid does not understand the
meaning of the words accountability or
irony
yeah so let's um
so let's talk about like i just found
god because that's something that comes
up that i
haven't seen yet or um
something to do with religion generally
speaking and it's i just found it
and more often than not they're trying
to repent for their sins from the past
um you'll see women with like three kids
from three different baby daddies
covered in tattoos uh carrying a bunch
of debt talking about how
jesus is her savior and uh she's gonna
wait until marriage
um yeah
whenever there's a conflict between
what's said and the life that is uh
lived always um you know believe the
latter
uh mike says my furby my fur babies come
first i've i don't think i've seen fur
babies come first that would be a new
one to me
he translates that as frustrated at life
because i'm unable to have children
you're going to help me feel better by
supporting my
menagerie with money and labor you are a
beta dog in this pack you don't get to
sleep next to mama that spot is reserved
for doggo
yeah that's um
yeah usually when you get these fur baby
types um or dog moms or cat moms
um that's a good indicator that you're
probably gonna wake up in the morning
with the dog's about three
inches from your face lying on the bed
uh between you
or a cat might
bite your toe or climb across your head
in the middle night wake you up that's
usually what you're going to end up
dealing with with the whole fur baby
crowd
uh let's see what else we got here
i like a guy who challenges me i like a
guy who takes me to nicer places than
the last guy
oh here's mops
uh dog mom uh dog lover mom for fur
babies i have an unhealthy attachment to
my pet because i have a crippling need
for unconditional love co-sign that oh
we've got a few more any quote from the
office my entire personality is based on
extremely overrated sitcom i agree the
office sucks that is one of the
lamest sitcoms i've ever seen but
it's usually uh you know there's
there's an audience for everything right
uh i'm sick of hookup culture equals men
toss me aside when they figure out i
have nothing to offer except sex
or she's got all 20 red flags
uh taking me on a fun activity for the
first date drinks are boring equals i
don't actually want to get to know you i
want to do fun things to post on my
instagram and i want you to pay for it
savage
moff is savage
you